I'm obsessed with Disney I'm very much a
Disney file
I'm usually a Jasmine all right wait why
are we here
we're gonna watch three Disney scenes we
have to like recreate this Oh some
things because I already feel like it
should be great unless they throne lady
in the dream yeah you know you took me
out yeah you did a heap at the paper
nothing obvious I'm amazing over me how
bad is this guy's restaurant doing that
he's got all this time to just entertain
these dogs I know she is like DTF so at
some point I've got to push a meatball
over with my nose with the meatballs for
cuter doing it right and that was
organically vital and I didn't look no
that's too short
we're not doing that that's all you had
it yay Oh offered Oh job
yeah yeah okay there's a whole roomful
major Beauty and the Beast vibes from
this set porridge Oh
gruel that's all they ever having a
gruel he was you never boy tips kind of
look tall he was just having
relationship goals making up the soup
she's like I'm eating like you people
pay a lot of money for oatmeal facials
oh it's good it's not you know a way to
eat Nick wipes it all over his sleeves
like a gentleman hey hey bad there's no
plain-ass porridge sock so whatever is
this how we use this oh you poor ha ha
ha so now you have manners okay ready
I know what this one is and I don't want
to do it oh no they're gonna tell me you
did not think these bugs look juicy is
pale oh god this is so disgusting
oh it's so Wiggly they actually look
pretty good no they don't
cream-filled I don't like that that's
what the fat caterpillar be careful what
these are not live level I'm not taking
it off Oh
since I'm funny and gummy worms you
don't want to grub mine stuck
well I got a big one you don't have to
be enjoying guys much oh the
cream-filled kind yeah
our situation hasn't improved here but
she is giving it an A+ effort oh oh
carrot that was interesting I did not
expect any of that it's a silly fun way
to have a snack with a friend how the
creators rely you know I think that he
just doesn't even used spoons it turns
out you never notice how crazy they
things in Disney movies our skin feels
nice and clean from the oatmeal see
that's a little bell fell for a great
skin now I just wish that that Peter Pan
food could come to life